how's Gomes my name is Pierre and
welcome to that didn't hurt at all it's
time for another Q & A baby cries fest
in what if your nipples could blow you
know the rave parties I would be like I
[Music]
would finally be popular do you smoke
weed drugs are bad m'kay what's your
favorite game that he played in last
year I I realize are you a potato
well one can dream can you show us your
morning routine I have a very strict
morning routine when I woke up so yeah I
think I can show
[Music]
turn that [ __ ] off why do you make
youtube videos okay this is actually a
secret but I'm planning to create a
cyborg army to invade Norway how long do
you want your YouTube career to last as
long as I have fun with it did you ever
think you would get 26 million
subscribers no I was proud when I got 26
subscribers so I think that answer your
question can you lick your elbow both
baby okay who's your favorite one
direction member 94 wait they tweeted
that to me 94 times you want to find out
that desperately I would say myself but
the only problem is I'm not in one
direction yeah when will you be doing
the catacombs challenge I think it's
June or July something can you lick the
thing closest to you all right breast
over here don't be don't be shy press
any inspirational quotes for the brows
yellow is evil so don't drink your piss
it's this for a new video now yes No can
you invent a new viral dance I realize
what it looks that is baby I call it to
working 2.0 get off me you [ __ ] don't
lick the mic
Jesus how do you drink without putting
the drink in your mouth just like this
now worth it and the remainder of the
video will be done looking like this I
should I should I should I should start
streaming and have a crotch cam god damn
genius girls have boob cams I have
crotch cam baby that's my sexy face
[ __ ] how are you not turned on right
now what is this oh I'll tell you what
it is it's to Fab Four you can somebody
dance without arms and legs yes it's
called a face dance I invented it
I'll show I'll teach you this is salsa
this is tango how dare you I have have
you ever seen these animals how would
you call that okay first one space
unicorn unicorn of death wannabe unicorn
and Ralph what's your worst fear
women with beards can you touch your
nose with your toe holding up to kiss me
on camera why do you hate me no oh it
smells really nice it's probably a guess
but ain't you a virgin
yes you're right I have eaten many
virgins they're delicious hasn't all the
fame made it harder for you in life
first of all not famous second of all
it's not like I have paparazzi oh [ __ ]
like that going on like it's my life is
the same as before I guess except I'm
Way more fabulous
would you rather our penis fits four
fingers or boobs fries I don't mind
seeing boobs all the time so boobs fries
I boob with scope are you part of the
Illuminati of course not
[Music]
[Applause]
can you seriously explain what is up
with you and the Ducks how did how they
started and what they're all about be
serious all right I'm gonna be thorough
and I'm gonna explain this in the best
way I can just what's your most fabulous
pose double kawaii [ __ ] shut up you're
not famous
can you play frozen let it go on guitar
let it go let it go can't stand this
song anymore let it go
let it go
it's been popular way too long I don't
care about this [ __ ] song
but they shape plays on I'm sorry I love
prose and please don't kill me I'm
serious I'm joking I'm sorry don't be
offended adele dazeem is one of my
absolute favorite vocal artists of all
time that's all for me bros hope you
enjoyed watching let me know if you have
any other questions I would love to
bring back their all their intro if you
want to make an intro posted to me on
Twitter hashtag peds intro and it
becomes a being bank also thanks a lot
for all the support as always it means
the world to me to stay awesome bros
there's a breakfast for you lovely bread
[Music]